The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What I want to do
today is to build on the movie
and the discussion
we had last time.
So I think in the movie, a lot
of themes appear that are also
in the chapter on health,
if you've read it.
A lot of the themes are kind
there, but in sort of some
random way.
And in the discussion we have
had, we also have elaborated
on the themes, but now what I
want to do is to try and put
them all together in a coherent
frame, give you a bit
more of specific examples that
are in the book specifically.
And we're, of course, going to
be talking about health in
particular with the angle of how
people choose which health
care to access, how people
choose what doctors to see for
what, why people are not doing
more preventive care in
investments, and things
like that.
Obviously, we are not doctors,
so we are not talking about
health from the point of view
of what could treat people.
We are taking this as given, and
then wonder how do we get
this stuff that can
treat people out
there in the landscape.
So we start with these things.
They are some technologies that
are known, that have been
demonstrated in [INAUDIBLE]
trials to be effective
and cheap ways to
promote good health.
Some examples of that include
bed nets to prevent malaria,
would include immunization,
which costs a maximum of maybe
$15 to $20 per child, and it's
one of the cheapest ways to
prevent child death.
Breast feeding, which of
course is free and is
recommended by WHO to be done
from one hour after birth
until six months, at least in
places where the water is not
very clean.
Oral rehydration solution, which
is basically a mix of
sugar and salt that you put in
water when they kid comes with
acute diarrhea.
That's not going to cure
whatever caused the diarrhea,
but it's going to prevent
dehydration, which is the main
reason why people
die of diarrhea.
And bleach, chlorine, that
you put in your water.
These are just a few examples
of things that have been
demonstrated to be effective,
and cost-effective, and cheap,
and accessible.
And one of the major puzzle and
frustration that we see in
world health is that these
investments just don't really
reach people, are not really
undertaken by people.
And so the question is, why?
It's certainly not because
they are not useful.
They save lives.
So you could argue what's
the value of a life?
Maybe it's not so
much worth it.
But the value of a life would
have been very, very low for
these things not
to be worth it.
But even if you leave that
behind, conditional on
surviving, you're going to do
much better if you have not
been very sick all through
your childhood.
We've seen that for deworming.
We've seen that if kids were
dewormed when they were
children, they were not sick
with worms, they are making
23% more every year, which
sounds to be like a
fantastically good
rate of return.
We're talking about the maybe
$1,400 in current dollars over
a child's lifetime for an
investment of less than $1.
And the same argument that
malaria also makes country's
poor and people poor has been
made for malaria by Jeff
Sachs, and Gallup who was also a
researcher at Harvard at the
time when Sachs was there at
the time, found that if you
control for other factors,
malarial countries, the
countries where malaria is
prevalent, have a GDP that is
30% lower than non-malarial
countries.
And what are the
other factors?
They are geography, latitude,
the climate, things like that.
You can actually see it on a
map from Gallup and Sachs
where it shows where malaria is
prevalent, at least where
it was in 1965.
And you can see that there is a
fair amount of bad luck that
is involved with malaria.
If you're in between the topics,
you're just much more
likely to be infected with
malaria simply because this is
environment where the mosquitoes
that carry the
malaria thrive.
So there used to be a lot of
malaria in Latin America.
There used to be malaria in the
American South once upon a
time, which is somewhat
above the tropic.
But otherwise, most of the
malaria is in Africa, Latin
America, India, and
Southeast Asia.
Keep this figure in
mind, that this is
where malaria is important.
And now if we look
at GDP in 1994--
oh no, that's malaria
in 1994-- it got
better in Latin America.
It didn't get much
better in Africa.
It got worse in India.
And this is GDP per
capita in 1995.
And you can see that you have
a striking reversal of the
colors, which is the countries
that are very dark in the
malaria picture are now
very light in the
GDP per capita picture.
So the results that he found in
the regression, [INAUDIBLE]
statistical bells and whistles,
is just translation
of that picture that basically
the dark countries in the
malaria picture are the light
countries in the GDP picture.
So that is no doubt
about this fact.
So on the [INAUDIBLE], this
article was very influential.
It was published in 2001.
Was very influential to bring
a push for the fight against
malaria as an economic type of
intervention that has a decent
rate of return.
Naturally you should do not for
compassion value, but for
economic purpose, fight malaria,
use bed nets and
things like that.
Now some people obviously
objected to that, saying,
well, that's not necessarily
a proof that malaria
causes the low GDP.
And what else could
be going on?
What else did they argue
was going on?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible that
is poor so it isn't able to
fight malaria?
So it has malaria because it has
[INAUDIBLE] below GDP, not
the other way around?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
It cold be that it takes some
money to fight malaria.
In fact, that's exactly what
Sachs is arguing, that it
takes some money to fight
malaria, so we need to help
the poor country.
And in fact, when you look at
the countries that got malaria
in 1965 and don't get it in
'94, or if you look at the
country that had little of
malaria in '65 and have a lot
in '94, this is some kind
of tracking pattern.
Basically, it mostly
disappeared--
not entirely, but mostly
in Latin America between 1965
and 1994, and nothing happened
in most of Africa.
In India, it actually increased
between 1965 and
1994, but the same increase
didn't happen in Sri Lanka,
which is the little dot
that is next to
India on the map here.
So why is it the case that given
the similar geographic
circumstances, in a sense, Latin
America managed to get
rid of malaria, but
not Africa?
Why is it the case that malaria
increased in India in
the same time it reduced
in Sri Lanka?
That's not entirely explained
by geography.
In fact, for the most part, it's
not explain by geography.
It is explained by the fact that
in Latin America, there
have been very sustained, large
effort to fight malaria
that we are going to talk
about in a moment.
They just basically
sprayed extremely
aggressively with DDT.
They drained the swamps.
They did all sorts of things
like that which managed to
control malaria, and they
managed to do it.
And the same thing happened
in Sri Lanka.
So if you compare Sri Lanka, for
example, and Tamil Nadu,
which is the part of India that
just faces Sri Lanka, for
the most part has the
same people--
at least part of Sri Lanka is
Tamil, even though they are
not very pleased to be there--
in Sri Lanka you had very
aggressive control of malaria
and pretty much the
disappearance of malaria.
In the meantime, in Tamil Nadu,
right next door with a
similar climate, your
get if anything
an increase of malaria.
And so this is not due to
geography or anything.
This is due to politics, and
your ability to organize your
people, and to organize
your country, and to
get something done.
And so it is likely to be the
case that if you're able to
get something done to control
malaria, you're just able to
get something done in general.
And if you're not able to get
something done with malaria,
you're not able to get something
done in general.
So maybe the same countries--
and this is not only true for
Sri Lanka--
that at the same time they
managed to control malaria,
they were also extremely
effective in getting out
preventive care for their
people, immunizations for
their people, preschools,
and things like that.
So Sri Lanka has a lot of
political problems, but from
the point of view of a country
that delivers social services
to their country, it's actually
quite effective.
So it's certainly the same
countries that have managed to
control malaria have managed to
do other good things, and
maybe this is why they have
[INAUDIBLE] in 1995.
So on its own, this correlation
is certainly not
sufficient to tell us that
there is a cause.
So before moving further, I want
to be able to answer this
question, which is we know that
the malarial countries
are 30% poorer than the
non-malarial countries.
To what extent can we say it is
due to malaria, and to what
extent is this the reverse
causality that the countries
that were good at controlling
malaria also managed to do
other good things?
And we can answer this question
precisely by looking
at those episodes where my
malaria was eradicated,
because malaria was eradicated
by very clear, specific action
that was taken at some point
in those countries.
And there are a series of
papers, one on the Americas,
which is the one we are going
to study now, one on what is
called malarial peripheries--
so that's Paraguay, Sri Lanka,
and one in India--
that looks at those eradication
campaigns and
tries to look at what is the
impact for a child of having
been born in a place that used
to be malarial after the
eradication campaign
rather than before.
So let's look at a very nice
study that is the study about
Latin America.
It's a study by a researcher
in Chicago called Hoyt
Bleakley, and what he looks
at is DDT spraying.
This is also interesting because
actually the question
of DDT spraying is a pretty
controversial one today,
because it's now pretty much
forbidden anywhere to spray
anything with DDT, because it's
not very good for you to
eat food that has been
sprayed with DDT.
On the other hand, maybe it's
also not very good for you to
get malaria.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So there is a little
bit of a conflict
between those two objectives
with a lot of people are
saying we should go back
to DDT and a lot of
people saying no.
For example, there is a huge
political fight in Uganda
between the organic farmers and
the rest of the country,
essentially.
The organic farmers don't want
any DDT anywhere near their
crop, obviously, because in
that case the European
community would put a stop
on their export to
other European Union.
And so any effort of eradicating
malaria with
spraying of DDT has been
stopped in Uganda.
But at the time, they were not
so worried about that, so
there was a big eradication
campaign in Latin America that
started around 1955 partly with
international funding.
And so they sprayed everywhere,
and they made sure
to try and get rid of
malaria everywhere.
They even sprayed under people's
roofs, like in the
eaves of a house,
the mosquito's
nest under the roof.
So they went there and put the
DDT there, which is probably
not excellent for people's
health directly, but very bad
for the mosquitoes for sure.
What the Bleakley study does is
to exploit the fact that if
you started in a region where
there was not so malaria to
start with, then the decline
in malaria was lower.
So here is one example
for Columbia.
This is cases of malaria
in Colombia by year.
You can see that in 1950, you
had a lot of malaria cases
every year.
The campaign started
roughly in 1955.
Intensive spraying started in
1958, and you start getting a
huge drop in the cases of
malaria country-wide.
So it's pretty effective.
Basically you go from 600 cases,
I think it's a month,
to about nothing, to close to
nothing, and that happened in
a very short period of time.
You could look at people born on
those times, but of course,
other things happen over time,
so we don't really
want to do that only.
But what you can do then is to
say, well, now let's look at
regions that got more malaria
before the campaign, and this
is the reduction in the
number of malaria
cases in those regions.
And of course, the more malaria
you got, the bigger
the reduction, because
the reduction was
pretty much to zero.
So if you started with 100, you
get about 100% reduction,
like in this place, Choco.
If you started with no malaria
at all, t then you get no
reduction because there
was nowhere to go.
It's a little bit
like the anemia
paper that we saw before.
If you started anemic, then
getting the pill makes you
non-anemic, but if you're
non-anemic, you don't benefit.
Same thing here.
This graph is by region,
so these are
all different regions--
Choco, Cauca, Narino,
Santander--
these are all regions.
And you can see that the regions
that had a lot of
malaria before the eradication
got the biggest reduction
between the post-campaign
to the pre-campaign.
So this is the reduction in
cases, and this is where you
started from.
So now what it's going to look
at is it the case-- take a
child who was born and who was
still a child before the
eradication campaign started,
and take a child who was born
after the eradication
campaign.
So take a child who was, let's
say, 10 by 1960 and a child
who was born in 1962.
And the child who is 10 by 1960
doesn't benefit from the
campaign whatsoever, but the
child who was born in 1962, by
the time he's born, malaria
is history.
So the young child relative to
the old child would benefit
more in a region where malaria
was a big problem than in a
region when it was
a small problem.
So what he is going to do next
is to put on the y-axis here
not the reduction in malaria
cases, but how much these
people make as adult, how much
a child born after the
campaign makes relative
to a child
born before the campaign.
What is this difference in
income between this, and is
the difference in income
related to the
malaria at the beginning.
This is called a difference in
difference, because you're
looking at whether the
difference in earning between
a young and an old cohort is
different in places that start
from a higher level.
What you are assuming when
you're doing that is that
there are no other factors that
are changing exactly at
the same time in the same way,
and we're going to see what we
can say about that.
Here is this graph that I was
talking about for Brazil now.
This is the pre-campaign
malaria intensity.
Don't worry about the axis.
It's sort of standardized at
zero, so for zero being the
median case.
And this is the income change of
those born in 1960, that is
those who were born after the
campaign, minus those who were
born in 1953.
It is their income later.
We measure the income much
later, in 1980, for example.
So in 1980, we measure the
income of those born in 1960
minus the income of
those in 1953.
This is all in log, so it's log
income in 1960 minus log
income in 1953.
And what we see is exactly
what we would expect if
malaria does make you poor,
which is the people who were
born in places like Mato Grosso
here where malaria had
been a huge deal beforehand, the
young people experience a
bigger increase in earnings
relative to the old people
than people, say, in Bahia where
malaria was not a big
deal to start with.
Do you understand this graph?
So I'm arguing that nothing
else changed between this
cohort in a way that's related
with malaria intensity, and
what could you argue
back to me?
What is the worry with
that assumption?
AUDIENCE: There might be a lot
of other factors that have
changed over time.
I mean, if you're born in the
'60s, then [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes. so the worry
is something else
might happen over time.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say,
sort of similarly that there's
probably a third, external
factor that's both raising
income and decreasing malaria
at the same time.
Since they have the same
effects, it's not necessarily
that they're affecting
one another.
There's a third thing that's
affecting both of them.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it could be something
affecting both of them, so
Brazil is just becoming
generally richer over time.
But this should be something
that is affecting
disproportionally Mato Grosso
than Bahia, right?
Because here, I'm not only
telling you that income
increases between these
two cohorts.
I'm also telling you that
increases faster in the region
that had more malaria
to start with.
But you could ask me, for
example, is it the case that
this place was poorer in the
beginning, so they had more
places to go?
As Brazil was becoming richer,
the poorer regions were
catching up with the older
regions, and this is what I
see here, just to catch up.
So that could be.
It's kind of one twist to the
point that both of you made,
which is as Brazil was growing,
maybe it is possible
that this region would have
been growing more anyway.
Now of course, I'm looking at
the income in 1980s, but these
are different cohorts, so maybe
the same places that had
a lot of malaria had
people who were
not very well educated.
And at the same times that I
took care of malaria, I also
built a lot of schools for them,
and I'm seeing these
guys are income increased
relative to the older ones.
It's just because I also
built a lot of
schools in Mato Grosso.
So that would be your third
factor that would be
differentially important
in the region.
So that is obviously
a real concern.
By looking at changes in income
over the importance of
malaria at the beginning, we've
gone one step towards
some credibility.
We're still very far from our
randomized trial, which would
involve randomly treating some
people for malaria, waiting 20
years, and seeing how much more
money they make like they
did with the deworming.
Such that it doesn't exist, so
we need to try to do the best
with what we have.
One way to verify this is that
we actually know exactly when
people start getting treated
for malaria, because the
campaign, if you go back to this
graph, was quite sudden.
In fact, we know the date at
which they started spraying,
and so we should have a pretty
clear idea of which cohort get
exposed and which cohort
are not exposed.
So instead of doing this kind
of graph for a broad cohort
and looking at the slope here, I
could say, well, let me do a
test, for example, if I did the
same graph for those born
in 1953 versus those
born in 1950.
If this graph was due to the
decline of malaria, what would
I expect if I, instead of doing
these differences, I did
1953 minus 1950?
What should I expect for my line
if the only reason why I
have an increasing line
here is due to the
reduction in malaria?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I should expect a flat
line, exactly.
Because the 1953 kids I
exposed to malaria.
So are the 1950.
So the differences between their
income should not be
related to how much
malaria there is
because no one benefited.
Now if instead I'm taking kids
who were born in 1950, so in
1970, and I'm comparing them
to the wages of kid born in
1965, what should I expect
for this line?
Now I'm looking at very
young kids, kids born
in 1970 versus 1965.
So we can go back to
this graph here.
What's the pattern in malaria
cases after the 1970?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there is no
further decline because there
is no malaria left.
AUDIENCE: It should be
flat as well, right?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
It should be flat as well, not
because everybody has malaria,
but because no one
has malaria.
So with malaria, we have a
pretty specific pattern as to
when I should start
seeing an effect.
If I'm thinking that the big
problem of malaria is when you
are very small kids, then
I should start seeing a
difference between the children
who were born just
before and just after
the campaign.
During that time of the campaign
scale up, I should
this effect being the larger and
larger, but for the young
cohort, it should flatten out if
I compare very young cohort
to somewhat younger cohort but
all of them got exposed.
And for the old cohort, it
should again flatten out,
because the old cohort has
not yet been exposed.
So I can now say something
more specific than why
generally the very youngest
versus the young are the
difference increase in
pre-malaria intensity, which
could well be correlated
with other things
happening at the same time.
He's doing that, so let me
guide you to this graph.
What is this graph?
It has the shape that I talked
to you about, right?
It has the shape of being flat,
and then increasing, and
then being flat again.
So what is this graph?
Each of these points is the
slope of a regression of this
kind, except that instead of
being 1960 versus 1953, it is
one year versus the other.
For example, this is everyone
relative to the oldest cohort.
Each dot indicates the strength
of the relationship
between pre-malaria index
and the index for
these particular cohorts.
So for example, 1900 versus
1910, 1911, 1912, et cetera.
I'm taking the difference
between the income of the
cohort born, say, 1910 minus
1900, and I'm plotting this
graph that is here
as a function of
the pre-malaria intensity.
So each of these points here is
a slope of a graph that is
this graph with instead of 1960
minus 1953 is, say, 1901
versus 1900, 1902 versus 1900,
1903 versus 1900, et cetera.
And this is plotted as a
function of the 1901, 1902,
1903, et cetera, the
cohort of both.
So all of these cohorts were
cohorts that were not exposed,
and we basically we see
not much of a line.
This line is superimposed, but
if you see this cloud of dots,
the cloud of dots is
not increasing.
So the difference is not
related to the malaria
intensity in those places.
Those places are generally poor,
but it's not correlated
with the malaria intensity.
For the younger cohort, we see
the slope keeps increasing.
The slope keeps increasing,
keep increasing, keeps
increasing until there is
basically no difference
between a region that initially
had a lot of malaria
and a region that didn't have a
lot of malaria, and then it
flattens again.
So these are the patterns that
we were expecting to see where
between the old cohort and the
slightly less old cohort we
see no difference until they
get exposed to the malaria,
and then it increases, and
then it flattens again.
So you could do still have the
type of factors that you get
we were talking about, that
maybe they were building
schools exactly at the
same time, et cetera.
But it would have to be relative
tricky to follow
exactly that pattern where this
is the pattern of the
malaria campaign going and going
and going, and we have
the points pretty much following
the expansion of the
malaria campaign.
This is not complete.
You still have to believe
that this is the
only thing that happens.
But it gives you a pretty good
sense that it must have been
the only thing that really
happened for this, because
otherwise why would
it have this
bizarre-looking snake shape?
Are you all OK with
this graph?
And do find it reasonably
convincing?
Yes, no?
No vote.
I find it reasonably convincing,
and I'm in the
business of doing [INAUDIBLE],
so I'm very skeptical of
anything that might be a
substitute to what I do.
But it's hard to imagine another
factor that would
follow so nicely the pattern
of the campaign.
What he does, then, is to run a
regression which is based on
this idea, and he concludes
that a child exposed to
malaria in childhood would
have an income that's 50%
lower than a child who had not
been exposed in childhood over
their lifetime.
So it's even better than
deworming, which is not
surprising because
malaria makes you
sicker than the worms.
But this is a very large effect,
so it's high, but it's
not absurdly high.
If you consider that deworming
is 23%, we are still in kind
of the ballpark of where
it makes sense.
So it suggests that childhood
malaria actually makes you
weak for the rest of your
life, and again we could
calculate what it means
for the lifetime of
someone, of an income.
So if an increase of 23% of
income with deworming make you
about, I think we had found,
$1,100 richer or $1,300
richer, this is about twice
that over your lifetime.
So if these effects are the same
in Kenya, it would mean
that avoiding malaria in
childhood would make you
$2,600 richer for
your lifetime.
Which brings the question that
Zachary has asked at the end
of the deworming lecture, which
is if that's so great,
why aren't people
are doing it?
So the question here becomes why
aren't countries doing it,
and why are people
not doing it?
So why aren't countries all
doing things like Latin
America did of intensive
campaign to try and get rid of
the affliction, so public
health kind of measure?
And if they're not going to do
it because they all have
difference or because there
is political, economic
consideration that prevents
DDT from being used or
anything like that, then why
aren't people at least buying
a bed net which costs $7 or
maybe $10 for a family?
It would mean the child would
have a pretty good chance of
being substantially richer
over the lifetime.
So that's kind of the mystery.
One thing just to close the loop
on Sachs is now that you
have this estimate, you can
calculate what is malaria
prevalence, in the countries
that have a lot of malaria,
how much more these people would
make if they didn't have
malaria and obtain a number that
is comparable to the 30%
differences that is in the
Sachs and Gallup article.
And what you find is a number
that is much, much smaller.
So you find that Sachs and
Gallup completely overestimate
the impact of malaria on GDP
even though the impact on
income is still positive and
still quite serious.
So you do find it's not 30%.
I don't want to give you the
number and then it happens not
to be the right one,
but the order of
magnitude is maybe a fourth.
But it's still pretty
significant and important.
So that gives us this idea of
why aren't countries spraying
and why aren't people
buying bed nets?
This question we could ask over
and over and over again.
I haven't seen a cross benefit
analysis of not getting
diarrhea all the time when
you're a child, but presumably
that's something probably
similar to the deworming
effect because worms are little
bit equivalent of
diarrhea in terms of getting
rid of your nutrition.
So why aren't people putting
bleach in their water?
Why aren't people buying
[INAUDIBLE] when they're sick,
and things like that.
So this is the mystery
we have to ask.
What we have already seen in the
previous lecture, and also
a little bit with nutrition,
us that preventive care is
characterized by two things.
One is it is very low demand,
and the second is it is a high
sensitivity to prices.
Let me show a graph.
This is the highest sensitivity
to positive
prices, and I'm going to show
you in a moment the high
sensitivity to negative prices,
which are incentives.
You've already seen some
of these numbers.
You've already seen the red
dots, which are coming from
the Dupas experiment in Kenya,
so this is this one.
This is the graph for bed nets,
so when bed nets are
free, you pretty much get them,
but when you need to pay
for them, a little bit of money
like $0.60, you're less
likely to get and use
them, et cetera.
What is interesting is that we
find the same kind of slope,
even steeper, for other goods
that are completely different.
So you find the same kind of
slope for clothing in Zambia
where if you ask people to pay
a little bit for clothing,
they're much less likely
to get to it.
So when they start to have to
pay $0.10, $0.20, $0.30, the
take up reduces a lot.
You're finding the same thing
for deworming in Kenya.
We actually briefly evoked
this when we were talking
about deworming when we saw
that people in the school
where they did the experiment,
at some point the NGO who was
in this sustainability kind of
mood, I guess, decided it
makes sense to ask
people to pay a
little bit do for deworming.
So they asked people to pay a
little bit, and basically what
happened is that the take up
went essentially to zero.
Let me try and get
the right point.
I think this is this one.
The take up went essentially to
zero when people had to pay
just a little bit
for deworming.
So you're looking at bed nets.
You're looking at clothing.
You're looking at deworming.
They're all very different
products presumably with very
different life time benefit, and
they pretty much all seem
to be on the same slope, which
is as soon as people have to
pay just a little bit, they
don't do it anymore.
So that's on the
negative price.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are some lines steeper
because people don't
see the value as much in paying
for the other things
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So what is
interesting is that except for
this one, all of the lines
are pretty steep.
So the question that we have
to ask here is why is that?
And one possible reason would
clearly be that people don't
see the value.
I'm going to get to
that in a moment.
Before we go to that, let's
see the elasticity with
respect to negative price, which
are small incentives.
So one thing that you already
noticed is that the rate of
immunization is very, very
low in some places.
It's higher in some others.
This is [INAUDIBLE], the places
where you saw the movie.
After the movie was finished,
one thing we noticed is that a
big problem seems to be that
kids are not immunized.
The immunization rate
was very, very, very
low, less than 5%.
So we decided the
try two things.
The first thing was that the
NGOs [INAUDIBLE] would work
with the government to do a
monthly camp for immunization.
So every month, they would take
the vaccines from the
government, go to the village,
and immunize whoever wanted to
come to be immunized.
And on top of this,
[INAUDIBLE]
also instituted a small
incentive to get immunized, so
that's a kilo of lentil.
Lentil is a [INAUDIBLE].
It's something people eat as a
source of protein, and a kilo
of lentil is about half
the minimum wage.
So this is a small, small
gift to go with it.
It's not like a large inducement
that if it's
something you don't want
to do it would
convince you to do it.
And these were the results.
There was also a set of control
villages that I'm not
showing to you.
I'm just showing to you the
effect of the incentive.
So comparing the camp
without incentive to
the camp with incentive.
Intervention B are the villages
where the lentils
were put in place, and you can
see that pretty much everyone
gets the first shot.
That's BCG.
And the second shot is
also pretty similar.
From the third, we start seeing
a difference, and from
the fourth, an even bigger
difference, and from the
fifth, the biggest difference.
The biggest difference is
between the more immunization
you need to get, the more the
small incentive matter.
So it seems that people are
not adverse to getting
immunized, but they sort of
lose interest or something
such that the more you get into
trying to get them to
complete the course, the more
the incentive is needed.
And this is a reasonably
large effect.
Overall if you look at the
effect on immunization, about
12% of kids who are in one
intervention received all the
immunization they should get, so
18% versus 38% if they get
the incentive.
We have three things that we
need to try and square.
One is the benefits are very
high, two is the demand is
very low, And three is the price
elasticity is very high,
both from the positive side
and the negative side.
And the question is, how
do we put all of
these elements together?
And the reason it is surprising
is that suppose we
take as given that the benefits
are indeed very high.
In that case, if people knew
it, if people don't do
something, it must mean that
they think that the cost is
also very high.
Why would they think the
cost is very high?
Maybe they think it's not
culturally appropriate.
Maybe they hate to get
their kids immunized.
Maybe sleeping under the bad
nets is extremely unpleasant,
or maybe they need the
money so much.
So if people are very sensitive
to the benefits, are
very aware of the benefits,
the only reason why they
wouldn't do it is because they
think the costs are huge.
For example, another fact that
we see both in rich and poor
countries, people are not very
likely to get a test for HIV
even and maybe particularly if
they have put themselves at
risk of HIV.
And one of the reasons that
people say is that people
realize that it would be good to
know your status, but they
are worried.
There is a fear of what will
you do if you find out that
you're positive.
Or there is also the social
factor of people knowing that
if you go to get tested, it
means you've done something
not right, otherwise why would
you have HIV if you are only
faithful to your husband
who is faithful to you?
So this is an example where
the benefits are high and
maybe the costs are also high.
But what is surprising is that
if people don't do these
things because the costs are
high, then I should not able
to bribe them to do these things
with a small incentive
like the kilo of lentil.
If people know the benefits of
immunization but don't do it
because they think that the evil
eye is going to be on the
kid, then a kilo of lentils
shouldn't convince them that,
no, the evil eye is going
to be good after all.
It's something that just doesn't
square together.
Or if people were so much aware
of the benefit, they
shouldn't take a bed net when
it's free but refuse to spend
a few cents for it.
So we can't have these three
things be true at the same
time, that people realize that
the benefits are very high,
the demand is very low,
and the price
elasticity is very high.
So it has to be that the
benefits viewed from the
people is actually not as high
as we think they are.
And there could be three
reasons for that.
One is that maybe people don't
care about their health or
don't care about the health of
their children, and that we
already sort of ruled out
because we've seen in the
movie that people are extremely
concerned about
their health.
They spend a lot
of money on it.
For example, they spend
7% of their
monthly budget on health.
That's a lot, and that is
something that we've seen in
the first lecture.
People do spend up to 5% to 7%
of their budget on health, the
very poor, except in countries
like Mexico where there's a
good public health system.
So it is not that people don't
care about health.
We have seen the example
of measles.
They don't vaccinate their kids
against measles, but if
the kids do get measles, they
spend a lot of money on the
hospital and on treatment.
So that's not because they
don't care about health.
Also when you ask them about
what stresses them out, they
tend to say that health is the
one thing that stresses them
out the most.
What makes them worried, tense
and anxious in the last month
is their health, or the health
of their kids, or the health
of their relatives.
So people do care about their
health, and they spend money,
but they don't spend it
on curative care.
They do spend it on directive
care, not preventive.
And they not only spend it
on curative care, but
on pretty bad ones.
We've seen these shots
and [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
So we can remove this.
So now why do people don't
use preventive care?
It's not because they don't care
about health, but it's
because there's something about
preventive care, that
either they don't really believe
that it works or
there's something else, that the
perception of the benefits
from today is relatively low.
Are government to
blame for that?
Another possible interpretation
is that people
are not getting those services
because they are
not generally available.
People don't even know
that they exist.
And we've seen in the movie that
to a certain extent, we
have reasons to blame
the governments.
Nurses are often absent, not
only in India, but everywhere.
There was a World Bank survey
conducted in several
countries, going to the little
hospitals where the nurses
are, found 35% of them absent.
And even when they're there,
they don't really spend a lot
of time on people, they don't
treat them very well.
There is this interesting 3-3-3
rule that Jishnu Das and
Jeff Hammer found in India.
That's three minutes, three
questions, three drugs.
That's what you get when you go
to see a doctor in a public
health facility.
They interviewed
three minutes.
They ask three questions.
They usually don't touch you.
They ask you what do you have?
And then they give you
three medicines
that you go away with.
So that's not excellent care.
And the government doctors
usually know more than the
private doctors who are
not really qualified.
They're all much
more qualified.
If you ask them to rank
vignettes, so you show them a
scenario of a child comes to the
clinic with diarrhea, and
you ask the right question to
evaluate what is this kid
suffering from, what should I
do, the public doctors do much
better than the private doctors
on those tests.
For example, when a pregnant
woman arrives with
preeclampsia, which is a
potentially fatal condition
that happens during pregnancy,
they are much more likely to
diagnose at its start and to say
that the right course of
action is to send them
to hospital.
So in principle, they know more,
the public doctors, but
in practice, they
do much less.
So even though they know what
they are supposed to do, when
you actually look at what they
do by putting someone to
observe their behavior, you
realize that they don't really
use their knowledge.
So that's a part
of the problem.
The nurses are not here, they
are desultory, they don't
really care, but it's not
the entire problem.
Because if you go back to the
immunization experiment that I
just showed you where the first
treatment was to have
perfect immunization camps--
every month, in your own
village, with a paraworker
that used to go to people and
try to remind them that the
camp is coming, and you should
bring your kids, and the
nurses who were vaccinating the
kids were good, caring, et
cetera people--
even when you do all that, only
18% of people or 12% of
people got immunized.
I think that's actually 18.
It's 6 plus 12.
18% of people got immunized.
So the bad services by the
government doctor is not the
only thing that there is to
blame, because even when you
provide good services,
you still don't get
a lot of them in.
So supply is not the
only reason.
Governments are not
only to blame.
What are we left with?
People don't demand preventive
care not because they don't
care about health.
Not because it's just not
available, because they don't
demand it even when
it's available.
So we are left with two
possible explanations.
One is that they understand the
benefits, but the benefits
are far away in the future,
and they discount those
benefits that are far away
in the future a lot.
And the second is that they
don't know the effectiveness
of preventive care just because
it's very difficult to
understand what works,
and why it works, and
why it doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: So in India we saw
that part of the reason is
also because they believed
in religious cures more.
Is that true in other countries
in the developing
world as well?
Is that predominantly
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, I think it's true
in general that people
construct all sorts of
interesting beliefs.
What is important is that
you have those beliefs.
On the other hand, if I give you
a kilo of lentils, those
beliefs are not strong enough
for you not to sell them for a
kilo of lentils.
So I think what is really
important is that it's not
that people think that
immunization is something bad,
because otherwise it would be
very hard to convince them
with small things.
It has to be that they just
don't think much about it one
way or the other.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
is there an example of a
[INAUDIBLE]
if people are embarrassed
assume something that
they [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That is a very interesting
question.
For example, you could say if
you have a cultural reason not
to do something, if you have
this social reason that you
are embarrassed, if I give you
a small incentive, you can
just say, oh, I've gone for
this small incentive.
And in fact, there was a very
interesting study that was
done which was trying to
shed some light on
exactly this issue.
It's a study where as part of a
survey, everyone got tested
for HIV, everyone who agreed.
But you didn't need to
get your results.
If you wanted your result, you
had to go pick them up three
weeks later at camp.
And so, at the end, people
[INAUDIBLE] a bottle cap where
they got a reward for picking
up their tests.
It could go from zero to
something like $1 in small
increments.
And in addition, the researcher
also randomized
where they put the tent where
you would get your results.
In some cases, it was put right
in the middle of the
village, so very convenient, but
very visible so everybody
would know that you're
going there.
In some places, it was put--
because it was random, so it
was like throwing a dart on the
village and saying we are
going to put it there-- it was
like in the middle of a field.
So a little bit far away, not
very convenient, but much more
discrete because no one would
see you go there.
And what they found is that,
number one, people were
extremely sensitive to the
reward, suggesting that it is
not some deep psychological
fear that were making them
worried to pick up their test,
because whatever this fear was
could be overcome by $0.10.
Now it could still be
the social thing.
So here, what do you think
they found with the tent?
Do you think more people got
their result when it was far
away or when it was close by?
First, what would we expect
under both, and what would we
expect under the social
stigma story?
AUDIENCE: The far away tent--
PROFESSOR: That the far
away tent would
have been more popular.
But in fact what they found is
the exact opposite, that the
far away tent was not
popular at all.
Nobody wanted to walk more
than a kilometer
to get their test.
And the close by tent
was very popular.
And furthermore, they also found
that the elasticity with
respect to this tent was much
smaller when there was a gift.
So when there was a gift, people
did walk a kilometer to
get their results, but when
there was no gift, people were
very sensitive to
the distance.
So those suggest that in this
case, in Malawi, [INAUDIBLE],
neither the social background,
not the psychological barrier,
were so big, and that if people
didn't get their HIV
result, it was more due to some
form of procrastination
or inertia or something
like that.
And that is something a little
bit surprising because
anti-retrovirals are available
in Malawi, so in principal if
you find that you're positive,
you can do something.
And if you find out that you're
negative, then you can
try and take some steps
to remain that way.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible they
just value [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So in this case, it
shows that-- so in the case of
the HIV, [INAUDIBLE]
all this money.
Exactly what this means is that
it has to be that they
value the small gains more than
the results of the exam.
And this is what is surprising,
which is you have
to say why is that the case when
it is something that it
should be so helpful to
you to know whether
or not you're positive?
Or with the lentils, it should
be so helpful to you that your
kid is immunized.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
followup question?
Does that mean that we should
reevaluate how we [INAUDIBLE]
so you're saying HIV tests
could potentially be more
helpful because they could
be cured [INAUDIBLE].
Shouldn't we be assigning more
weight to [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What we have seen
is it doesn't mean that we
should put more weight on
instant gratification things
than we do.
What this means, in my view, is
that we should understand
why there is this disconnect
between what doctors know, for
example, and what people feel.
Because that's kind of the
source of the mystery, that
there is this big tension, and
it has to be about the
perception of the benefits.
And one aspect of this is this
future versus present, and one
aspect of this is whether
you understand what
the benefits are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HIV testing, I think the
results make sense just
because if your test
comes out HIV
negative, well then, great.
You're just going to go
on with your life.
And if it comes out positive, is
there really that much you
can do about it if you're
[INAUDIBLE]--
I thought those [INAUDIBLE]
were very expensive.
PROFESSOR: So, in Malawi and
in several other African
countries, it's actually
available for free.
So you can do something.
It's not going to cure you,
but it's going to greatly
improve your life for
the time to come.
People might not fully
realize that.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
[INAUDIBLE] certainty
of [INAUDIBLE]
if you're getting [INAUDIBLE]
a certain cost [INAUDIBLE]
really uncertain.
And the second question was
about with the lentil
distribution, can you play
with short term kind of
[INAUDIBLE] cost?
So people can procrastinate
indefinitely to always get a
pack of lentils when you get a
vaccine, but if you only get
lentils on the first day of the
month, then wouldn't that
really lower the cost today
relative to tomorrow?
PROFESSOR: That's a
very good point.
Why don't I table the questions
until we give a bit
more context, and
we'll go back to
exactly these questions.
They really have two problems.
One is that you might not know
that it's worthwhile getting
your HIV test because you might
not know that you are
entitled to the drugs or that
the drugs will really help
you, or you might not know that
getting immunized is so
beneficial.
And the other is the benefits
are in the future, the cost is
now, and that leads people
to procrastinate.
Let's go over both things.
The first thing is learning
about health care, and we had
a little bit of that discussion
already last time.
But most diseases are
self-limiting, that is, they
just go away by themselves.
You don't know that because
how would you know?
You start with a theory that
someone has told you that as
soon as you're sick, you should
get a shot to put the
medicine right into
your blood.
And if you don't do that,
you won't get better.
And then if the market is
unregulated, like it is in a
lot of developing countries
where anybody can establish
themself as a doctor--
for example,
we saw that in India--
then you have a very strong
demand for shots and someone
who's willing to supply it.
You're never going
to experiment
away from the shorts.
So every time you're sick,
you're going to get a shot,
and you're going
to get better.
And so you're going to think
that your theory was, once
again, vindicated because you
were sick, you got a shot, now
you get better.
That is going to further
reinforce your belief that
this was a good theory and
further make you very
suspicious of not
getting a shot.
Now of course, if you
experimented once of not
getting a shot, you would
see, oh, I have
gotten better as well.
Progressively, your [INAUDIBLE]
would move towards
something closer to the truth,
which is, let's say, 95% of
the time you get better with a
shot, and 90% of the time you
get better without the shot.
But if your beliefs were 95%
of the time you get better
with a shot and 10% you get
without a shot, then mostly
you're never going
to experiment.
You're never going to know,
and you're continuing with
this very strong belief.
So this is for self-limiting
diseases.
And now if you take a disease
like diabetes, or chest pains,
or something like that that
doesn't go away with the shot,
when you go to a doctor and get
a shot, it doesn't go, so
progressively your [INAUDIBLE]
are going to be that everything
is useless, at
which point you might as
well go to [INAUDIBLE].
It might be why we see this
paradoxical result of people
spending a lot of money on
diseases that would cure
themselves anyway and not doing
really any attempt to
treat seriously the
diseases that they
should treat seriously.
Because the disease that they
should treat seriously are
beyond the ability of the
Bengali doctor to handle,
because first order,
the Bengali doctor
can't handle nothing.
So the Bengali doctor end
up spending [INAUDIBLE]
distributed this antibiotics
for diseases that fixes
themselves anyway.
People don't get any form of
treatment for things that they
should really try and treat,
which would be much more
complicated to treat, and
you get this no learning
equilibrium that is very
difficult to get away from.
And it will be harder to
attribute it to nothing, so
the tendency to over medicate
is a very [INAUDIBLE]
tendency.
And in fact, this tendency to
over medicate is not something
that you only have in
poor countries.
In rich countries, when
you go to the doctor
and they tell you--
like when I arrived in the US,
my first doctor visit was you
should breathe under the shower,
and I was like, what
are you talking about?
Like in my country, I would
have gotten an antibiotic
immediately.
So our own tendency is always
you must do something about
me, like you should be
able to do something,
not just let it go.
And the only reason why doctors
don't do it here is
because they are under
guidelines, and they have
regulations from their
hospital, from their
association, from what
they have learned to
not do these things.
Now preventive care is even
worse because with preventive
care you are taking an action
today to prevent something to
happen in the future, but
far away in the future.
For example, you breast feed
your child so that the child
gets stronger in the future and
doesn't get sick in the
future, or I guess with
breastfeeding it's also avoid
diarrhea in the meantime.
But for immunization, you get
immunized, and then you don't
get measles at some point.
So linking the two is
very difficult.
And I think Noah had made this
point with respect to
deworming, it's even harder when
you're immunized against
communicable diseases, because
even if you do get immunized
and people around you don't get
immunized, if there are
enough people who
get immunized,
then no one gets measles.
So the fact that you got
immunized protects other
people around you as well, so
what you're seeing is that,
oh, this whole immunization
thing, now I got it, and now,
yes, it's true my kid doesn't
have measles, but no one has
measles, so clearly it is not
because I got immunized that I
didn't get it.
Now of course, it is because
collectively there was
immunization around, but it's
very difficult to infer.
If you remember the results of
the deworming study, when
people had more friends around
them who got the deworming,
they were actually less likely
to get dewormed.
And one possible explanation
is that initially they were
convinced by the people that
deworming would make their
kids less sick, but then they
saw all of these kids around
them who don't get dewormed and
don't get sick either, and
so they're saying what
is the point?
I don't need to do it.
So this is basically
not something that
we can learn ourselves.
In a lot of our own lives, for
example if you try to go
afield, and you do something,
like, for example, plant in
rows instead of scatter plant,
you see immediately that your
plant is doing better.
So you can progressively
experiment with better
techniques, and you will
get better at it.
So in most of our lives, we
experiment things, and we kind
of see the results, or at least
we have a sense of what
the results are, and we can
adjust our behavior.
With health, our own
experience, or own
observations, is very misleading
most of the time.
We think we can infer from our
actions something that we
cannot really infer.
It's not because of the medicine
that we got better.
We think we can infer from
not seeing a result from
immunization that immunization
was not working, et cetera.
So it is just not possible to
learn, because the object is
too complicated.
So how do we learn
about health?
The answer is we don't.
Well, you guys might because
you've first taken biology, so
you have some sense of it.
But most of us just don't have
anything to do, no real
understanding of why medicines
are working unless we have red
stuff on the side.
But still, when our doctor
says you don't need an
antibiotic to cure that,
we trust them.
We trust them because they have
spent a lot of money and
a lot of time getting a health
care education, and we believe
that there is something
into it.
And that trust, same thing
with immunization.
We get immunized because we are
told to get immunized and
not because we understand
how it works.
Not at all.
So it's got nothing to do with
our education or our superior
intelligence.
And in face, this trust
is quite fragile.
You see it eroding reasonably
easily when something happens.
so for example, there has been a
few well-publicized articles
linking the measles vaccine,
which is MMR--
Measles something Rubella,
MMR vaccine--
and autism.
There's been some court cases,
et cetera, which have been
actually the people who were
suing against the vaccine have
generally lost.
But despite the fact, there
is pretty much ingrained
somewhere in the collective
mentality the idea that, in
fact, MMR vaccines might
cause autism.
And as result, there is
kind of an epidemic of
non-vaccination for measles
which has led in some places
to measles outbreaks that you
didn't used to have before.
So these things are actually
reasonably fragile.
If you're interested in that,
there is a book by a New
Yorker journalist called
Michael Specter called
Denialism which has a very
interesting chapter on this
vaccination in the US.
And this vaccination in the US
story reminded me of polio
vaccine in India.
Polio vaccine is one thing
that for some reason the
government of India has decided
that they are going to
really do, so most kids do
get the polio vaccine.
But there are pockets where it's
not being done, and they
tend to be mostly in villages
which are refusing the polio
drugs, and the reason is that
they say it's an attempt to
sterilize us.
And why would they have this
idea that might sound a little
bit bizarre?
It is linked to the fact that
long time ago, during the
emergency period which is a when
Indira Ghandi suspended
the civil liberty, there was
a big drive to encourage
sterilization of people who
had at least two children.
And this big drive took a shape
that with sometimes
quite unacceptable, including
rounding up people who had no
desire being sterilized,
including lying to people
about what was being done
to them, et cetera.
And this has created this huge
mistrust, in particular in the
Muslim population, about what
government's trying to do to
them under the guise of doing
something good for them.
And so there are regions where
people will simply not accept
to be immunized.
This is an extreme.
Those are two extreme cases
where people have a strong
belief against.
If you do that here in this
region, giving people lentils
to immunize them
will not work.
In fact, it might be
counterproductive because they
might think that you're trying
to fool them like they did
with the sterilization
already.
But more generally, the fact
that people are generally
indifferent about preventive
care might be related to the
fact that they don't think
there is some grand
conspiration.
They just think you're
bullshitting them like you
always are.
And once this trust is eroded,
then it's very
difficult to go back.
AUDIENCE: I think in America,
don't most people figure out
all these things about
vaccination and
preventive care work?
There's a reason because they
have a family care doctor who
tells them?
There's some figure of authority
that you can trust
that tells them that
these things work.
I'm guessing most Americans
don't know how vaccines work.
PROFESSOR: That's
exactly right.
AUDIENCE: So if you have the
same thing in India or in
Africa, figures of authority
that have been mandated by
some government agency or some
school that tells them that
they know about this stuff,
telling them that, wouldn't
that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
exactly right.
The question is, who is this
figure of authority?
In the US, except for examples
like this autism in the US
where there was some idea of
conspiracy theory, where big
pharma is trying to make our
children autistic and things
like that, except in those
cases, we have a
basic sense of trust.
That if your doctor tells you
to do something, you think
they must know what it
is they're doing.
You don't understand what
is going on, but
you still trust them.
But the problem with a place
like India, for example, is
whether this authority figure
exists or whether they are
interested in preventive care.
So in India, this sterilization
campaign that I
was talking about had very, very
long-lasting damage of
convincing people that the
government was quite liable to
lie to them on any matter
involving health.
So people are quite suspicious,
and if enough tell
them you should get polio drugs,
they're thinking he's
trying to do something
else to me.
She's trying to get
me sterilized.
So once the trust is eroded,
someone who is mandated by the
government is someone who a
priori you should not believe,
so that the government becomes
a negative, not a positive.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] like
a Muslim doctor [INAUDIBLE]
saying [INAUDIBLE] the fact that
we've been mandated by
the government or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
[INAUDIBLE]
so you would need also
authority figure once
you've eroded it.
And once you've eroded the
trust, it takes a lot of time
to rebuild it again,
but you can have
other authority figures.
So in Phuket, for example, in
the movie, you remember, there
is a doctor from an NGO who is
talking about the Bengali
doctors sometimes being good,
sometimes being bad, and about
the kids with the long hair.
So this doctor used to work in
a small hospital run by a
couple doctors.
In this area, everybody was
immunized, everybody was
always going to them, everybody
was getting
preventive care because that
have established that trust.
But the point of it is how do
you establish the trust?
They were on a very small area,
the government has a lot
of power to reach a lot of
people, but once they have
misused it once, or twice, or
three times, the temptation to
use the trust that you have from
the people to get them to
do things that are not
necessarily in their interest
is very strong.
And once you have done
that, then it's
difficult to get back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
For example, in the movie that
we watched, there were a lot
of people who would choose
to go to the [INAUDIBLE]
instead of going to
the actual doctor.
Is there any initiative where
people actually use those
entities to actually provide the
population with medicine?
I know in Brazil, there's parts
of it where for a lot of
people who were dying with
diarrhea, people use like
these women that were supposed
to be known to help them
somehow, and they were more not
really like the typical
doctor, but they were more
like the cultural thing.
And [INAUDIBLE]
those persons to deliver
the [INAUDIBLE]
or dehydration solution to
actually help those people who
were dying.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think that's a great idea.
I think it's been tried.
The problem is that then you
need to be able to control
these people, because they
already have some authority,
and then you give them some more
authority, and then you
really are wary of what
they start to say.
So you don't want to transform
them into a collection of
Bengali doctors that are going
to give them-- if the
[INAUDIBLE] start giving
antibiotics,
then you're in trouble.
But your idea is exactly right,
is that basically once
you've shut down the traditional
channels, which
would be your family doctor
that you trust, how do you
reconstruct some measure of
communication that comes from
other channels?
And these could be
the [INAUDIBLE].
These could be television that
a lot of people watch.
In Brazil, actually, it's
not about health,
but it's about fertility.
People were all watching the
soap opera, and in the soap
opera, the cool people have
very few children.
And there was a study that
was done looking at the
penetration of the soap opera.
It was on network TV, so it's
not always available, but it
became progressively available
in part of Brazil.
So you can follow the fertility
as it becomes
available in the different
part of Brazil.
And you observe two interesting
things.
One is that as it became
available, people had fewer
kids, and the second is those
kids tended to be poor.
Like the name of the soap opera
heroine, the kids had
started to have those names,
which is like the other.
So other things like that you
could try and view imbue.
I haven't seen evolutions of
trying to get health messages
to go through the television,
but these are things that you
could also try, so use
those other channels.
In the last five minutes, I want
to say something about
the present and the future.
That's something we are going
to get back again, which is
kind of elaborating on the point
you were making before.
Another problem is that the
preventive health cost are
incurred today, but the benefits
are in the future,
and furthermore, as you
pointed out, in
the uncertain future.
Like, it is going
to happen later.
So even if you know that it
prevents getting measles, you
don't know whether you would
really have gotten measles,
and it's in the future,
sometime later.
And it turns out, which you
can easily verify from
introspection, is that human
beings-- not only the poor,
but the poor, the
rich, everyone--
tends to put much more weight
on the present than in the
entire future.
This is something different than
your regular discounting
that today is more important
than tomorrow, and tomorrow is
more important than day after
tomorrow, et cetera.
This is something that today is
much, much more important
than tomorrow, and then tomorrow
and day after,
tomorrow is little bit more
important than day after, and
day after a little bit more
important than the following
day, et cetera.
But today is much, much more
important compared to the
entire future in what we're
thinking about.
That's true for consumption, so
you would like to save for
your retirement, but
not starting
today, starting tomorrow.
It's the same with time.
I gave you the flexibility of
when you're doing essays for
this class, but I did warn you
that in my experience, a lot
of students will decide to do
the five last essays because
they think from today that
it's the absolute optimal
thing to do because now
you're very busy.
But of course at the end of
the semester when all the
projects are due, and the
exams too, you'll
have much more time.
So this is something that it
doesn't take much to realize
that there is this problem.
And not only we have this
problem, but we are not fully
aware of it.
Because if we were fully aware
of it, you would write me an
email and say can I please
commit to a schedule of essays
and ask Laura or Millicent
to enforce them.
We realize to some extent,
but we overestimate.
We're thinking that today, the
present is very important, but
that tomorrow we will start
being reasonable people again.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And now tomorrow
comes, and tomorrow becomes
today, and again today is so
important, and we get fooled
by ourselves like
that repeatedly.
So with the immunization, you
can think this can be
available every month.
So you're today I'm just so
busy, I can't go, but I will
go next month.
Then next month comes, and
then it's next month.
And next month is now today,
and you're so busy
that you can't go.
And that's way, you could
procrastinate.
AUDIENCE: After [INAUDIBLE]
an experiment with decreasing
incentives?
Like if you said people who turn
in essays, like the first
five would get 10 extra points,
and the next five
wouldn't get 10 extra points,
most people would do the first
five essays just
to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're exactly right.
The intuition is exactly right,
which is if we suffer
from things like that, giving
us small incentive to act
today rather than tomorrow
will help.
For example, this idea of saying
if you're doing the
first five, you're getting 10
extra points for the first
five, that helps.
I could also have a
disincentive, which is to say
you get 10 negative points
if you give them later.
In principle, if you have some
awareness of this problem, you
should like this program,
because you should like the
idea of putting some incentive
on yourself to act today
rather than tomorrow.
And so with preventive care,
the problem is that in the
developing world, the costs tend
to be higher than for us.
With immunization, like not only
you have to go, but half
of the time she's not there,
and all of that.
So it's constructed exactly
the other way, which is a
small cost, everything becomes a
little bit more complicated.
In our lives, everything is
structured to make the small
cost less costly, and also
to impose schedule on us.
For example, for immunization,
you have a calendar that is
given by the government that
you have to follow.
Otherwise the kids can't go to
school, but since kids have to
be in school, you have
to follow that.
So it's a form of incentive,
very strong incentive, to make
it compulsory.
And the lentils is saying
there is a small cost of
going, but in extent of this
small cost, you get a small
benefit, which is the lentils.
And so that can help
people to go.
And you're right that combining
your two ideas, I
could say you're going to get
a bigger incentive if you
follow the schedule than
if you go at any point.
And that way, that gives
us a strong sense
of doing it on time.
So these procrastination issues,
combining with the
fact that people have probably
not a full understanding of
the benefits, could explain why
we see this huge waste.
Because we really have to call
this as a waste, all of this.
Kids who are not immunized.
Kids who are not dewormed.
Kids who drink dirty water,
and adults also.
And that could come from this
combination of not fully
understand the benefits, not
trusting what you are told,
and the disproportionate
importance of small cost.
How can we solve it?
Well, we can solve it by making
things as easy as possible.
This is what we benefit from.
When you open the tap in your
water, there is chlorine that
comes, right?
You don't have to remember
to add the tablet.
So making things automatic
and defaulted.
And when it's not possible, like
you're not a very well
organized country like India,
giving people small rewards
that are offsetting the small
cost, if possible exactly in
the way that you're talking
about it, which is [INAUDIBLE]
people to do it later
rather than earlier.
That means that charging a small
amount for goods may be
totally counterproductive
because you might lose a lot
of people when you have your
entire infrastructure to
deliver the goods.
And giving small incentive might
actually be productive.
The last word would be--
and that's the question of the
bed net that we spent a whole
lecture on-- is it going to have
some bad effect in the
future if people are used to
be helped in this way?
And I think the answer
is two prongs.
Some of these problems
are here to stay.
It's not that we have them
today, and it will be better
in the future.
We always have those problems.
That's why immunization in the
US is free and compulsory, and
it's going to be forever.
We're not expecting that one day
people will now understand
the value and will start
doing it on their own.
Secondly is when we think about
the dynamic effect, we
also have to include learning.
And because of the lack of trust
and people don't just
believe you because you say
something, the fact of giving
people an occasion to try for
themselves by making things
very easy and cheap may actually
have those dynamic
effects that are positive
because of the learning.
Which is exactly what we
saw with the bed nets.
We don't need to go over it
again, but with the bed net,
people were probably relatively
suspicious about
the effectiveness of
those bed nets.
You give them one--
[INAUDIBLE] not willing
to pay the cost.
You give them one for free,
and then they realize the
benefits are bigger than what
they were, and that can
overcome the small cost to get
the benefits in the future now
that they're convinced that
those benefits actually exist.
So we're done with health, and
we are going to start with
education next time.